[تصفيق]
في ايران تتشابه الساحات كلها تعيش
بالمتظاهرين اما هوائها فمسموم بغازات
تدمع العيون اطلقتها قوه الامن لتفريق
صفوفهم واخماد حناجرهم التي من فكت تصبح
بالمراه والحياه والحريه منذ مقتل الشابه
مهساين
وذهابا الى ساحه اصفهان فان رائحه موت تعم
المدينه التاريخيه لا سيما في ميدان
الشهيد علي خان الذي قد يصبح من صدت اعدام
لعشره المحتاجين يقولوا شهود عيان لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه ان تركيب المنصه هناك
بدا بالفعل وقد يكون امير مصر ازداني
اللاعب الايراني السابق في فريق تراكتور
لكره القدم اول من يلقى حتفه بعد ان اتهمه
النظام بالمشاركه مع مجموعه مسلحه يزعم
انها قتلت العديد من عناصر الامن ففي هذه
الساحه و ديسمبر
قد تنتهي كل الاحلام شهر النهايات ربما
يراه النظام الايراني فرصه لتنفيذ موجه
اعدامات حيث اكدت سي ان ان بان القضاء
يسرع في اصدار الاحكام وتطبيقها ووفق
بيانات الشبكه فان 43 شخصا على الاقل
سيواجهون اعداما وشيكا بينهم معاشره اشخاص
في اصفهان والعدد يصل الى الضعف بحسب
ترجيحه وسائل اعلام ايرانيه
عائلات المعتقلين مذعوراء ابنائها خلف
القضبان والعالم يستعد لاستقبال عام جديد
ومخاوف من انشغال بالاحتفالات ونسيان ما
يجري على ارضهم ورغم ذلك صامدونهم
الايرانيون حتى لو كان هذا العام شهد اكثر
الايام فتا فيما عرف في زاهدان بسم الجمعه
الداميه اسراء الصغير العربيه